the power system in one piece is one of
the most unique and innovative you'll
find in anime instead of a complicated
energy force that you struggle to wrap
your head around or some quirky magic
what you get is a fancy looking fruit
that gives its eater incredible powers
and a bad taste in the mouth it's called
a devil fruit but you already know that
don't you and it comes with a forstean
deal those who eat it and inherit its
powers automatically lose the ability to
swim
and survive in water devil fruits aren't
that complicated there are just three
categories paramecia
logia and zoen paramecias are the most
common type and give their users an
endless variety of abilities
logia fruits are rare and their users
gain the ability to create
manipulate and transform into some sort
of natural element
zoens create human animal hybrids devil
fruit powers vary wildly some are more
basic than others like the ability to
make your target turn into stone or to
turn your own body into sand well we're
talking basic by one piece standards of
course
others are simply crazy imagine gaining
the ability to grow countless limbs on
your body or being able to manipulate
stone to the extent that you can turn an
entire country
into a part of yourself within this
insane variety there are some devil
fruit powers that are best described as
overpowered they give their owners such
godlike powers it's no wonder how anyone
can stand up to them that brings us to
the subject of today's video which is
the top 10 overpowered devil fruit
powers in one piece let's take a look at
them
kicking off this list is the string
string fruit eaten by
don quixote doflamingo when it comes to
doffy his devil fruit power is one of
the last things about him that strikes
you that's because he's such an
intriguing character even without it
there's the way he looks
his evil grin and his raspy voice there
are multiple personalities that he's
cultivated a fallen noble turned pirate
a ruthless underworld arms dealer a
slave driver and the man who thinks
nothing of killing his own brother
there's his haki prowess which makes him
one of the biggest threats around
you might be forgiven if you think the
string string fruit's powers aren't that
special but take a closer look and
you'll find it's a deadly power it gives
doffy the ability to create an unlimited
number of
tiny razor-sharp strings that he can
manipulate at will
these harmless looking strings can slice
buildings in half create a cage large
enough to enclose an entire country turn
people into puppets and even repair the
user's internal organs embooing the
string with haki makes them even more
deadly it's a power truly worthy of its
wielder
[Applause]
[Music]
more
oh
us at number nine is the power of
admiral kizaru's glint glint fruit the
admiral might not look much like a
threat
but he has the most powerful and
versatile devil fruit power among the
marine higher-ups which makes him a
class
a hazard and the only human capable of
riding a cannonball the glinkling fruit
blesses kizaru with the powers to create
control and transform into light turning
him into a light human this means he can
travel at the speed of light
making him almost unstoppable with his
power of light hizaru can shoot high
speed high precision laser beams from
his fingertips and feet these lasers
have the same piercing effects as
bullets shot from a gun additionally he
can blind his opponents with his light
or create weapons of light such as a
sword to fight them it's no wonder then
that he gave the straw hat such a hard
time before the skip
[Music]
um
i think we all know why this makes the
list a power to continuously regenerate
is pretty overpowered isn't it
especially if you're in a battle shonen
series not to mention how cool it looks
in its fully transformed form
this is one of the five mythical zoen
we've seen in the one piece canon
marco's control over his transformation
seems to be one of the greatest among
other zoen users shown so far it allows
him to transform into a legendary
phoenix granting him the ability to fly
and control phoenix fire which doesn't
just heal him but can be used to heal
others wounds too one of the reasons why
it doesn't get higher is because
offensively it's not as useful as some
of the other devil fruits on this list
coming in at number seven is the pawpaw
fruit
[Music]
don't be deceived by how adorable it
sounds or by the fact that it gives its
user soft pink padded paws and leaves
q-poor imprints whenever it's used
behind its unassuming name this devil
fruit holds one of the most mysterious
powers ever seen it allows bartholomew
humor its user to deflect
anything from enemy attacks to people
and even ghosts and send them flying at
the speed
of light it endows him with great speed
and the ability to compress
air and turn it into a massive explosion
he can even push out the pain in a
person's body put it inside an air
bubble and transfer that pain into
another's body perhaps because of his
gentle nature humor doesn't always use
his devil fruit powers to hurt others
when he sends the straw hats flying in
different directions
all of them arrive safe and sound at
their destinations despite having
travelled in his air bubble for three
days and three nights
[Music]
the rumble rumble fruit allows its eater
to create control and turn into
lightning move at lightning speed and
send 200 million volt lightning bolts
crashing down on its opponents that's
not all the user can also
create control and transform into
electricity
merge with and manipulate metal hear
electrical
sound waves many many miles away and
even jump start their own heart with a
jolt of electricity
touching a person with the power of the
rumble rumble fruit means being fried
with hundreds of thousands of volts of
electricity it's no wonder that it's
user nl has the nickname god attached to
his name
it's just his bad luck that he happened
to run into the one person
capable of withstanding his electrifying
personality
a certain rubber man by a minor
character's account the rumble rumble
fruit is the most powerful of the rare
logia fruits
[Music]
at the halfway mark now we have a
sinister power in the hands of a 10 year
old like the poor poor fruit the hobby
hobby fruit has a harmless
even cheerful ring to its name but it
holds a power so
terrible it's capable of enslaving an
entire population the devil fruit gives
its users the power to turn people into
toys with just a touch
control their every movement erase
others memories of them while tragically
allowing them to retain their own it
also gives the person who eats it the
gift of eternal youth which is why
sugar a member of the don quixote family
and the owner of the hobby hobby fruit
hasn't aged a day in 12 years
what makes this fruit even more sinister
is the fact that sugar uses its powers
to help doffy create a huge
underworld in dressrosa that runs on the
backs of slaves whilst presenting an
outward picture of a prosperous and
peaceful country despite being
overpowered the hobby hobby fruit has
one
big weakness which we won't be revealing
suffice to say it's the reason why usopp
becomes god usopp in one of the most
unusual power-ups in shonen anime
number four the dark dark fruit
it's time to go z because the next entry
on the list is the despicable
blackbeard's terrifying power of the
dark dark fruit
the power of darkness in this fruit
gives its users the ability to
manipulate
darkness this manifests in the form of a
black hole or void that swallows
everything in its wake be it a person or
an entire city though it doesn't
necessarily destroy them in the process
when blackbeard wields it the black hole
also spits out what it swallowed the
yonko is able to pull his opponent into
the dark abyss with a mysterious
gravitational force but
the most frightening power of the dark
dark fruit is that it can nullify all
other devil fruit powers provided
blackbeard is in physical contact with
their users the history behind this
devil fruit is just as menacing as its
abilities
blackbeard acquired the fruit by killing
a crewmate who had found it first
the dark dark fruit was also
instrumental in the capture of ace and
subsequently one of the most important
developments in the one piece story
truly dark stuff this one
[Music]
in the third spot is the heart-shaped
op-it of benomi fruit which is
as bizarre as it is powerful it gives
its user trafalgar law divine
surgical skills and the ability to cure
incurable diseases earning him the
nickname
surgeon of death but it's how the power
works that makes it so absurdly
wonderful with it law can create a
spherical space he calls a room within
which he can control the placement of
any object or person using a force
pretty much like teleportation
in the room law can dismember people
without hurting them switch their hearts
and their personalities and switch
himself with them
all with an object oh and he could turn
them back to how they were as well
if he's in the mood despite being a
serious looking guy law's known to use
his powers in deviously funny ways look
at the way he cut kinemon up into tiny
pieces
stack the pieces up any which way even
attaching his legs to his back on a more
serious note though the opio binomi
fruit allows its users to give another
person eternal life at the cost of the
user's own life it's definitely a
godlike power
[Music]
taking the runner-up spot is the tremor
tremor fruit which according to admiral
sengoku
holds the power to destroy the world and
that's no exaggeration it's considered
the strongest of the paramecia fruits
and a rival to the strongest logia
fruits the person who consumes this
devil fruit can cause huge cracks in the
air with just a punch these cracks in
turn
create large shock waves which bring
about earthquakes and tsunamis that can
destroy
entire islands the user can also flip
large objects and places on their head
an extremely frightening way to use this
power is by holding one's enemy by their
head and concentrating the vibrations
around it defeating the opponent
instantly in the hands of whitebeard the
world's strongest man the tremor tremor
fruit was never used for evil rather we
can safely assume that its powers were
used to protect many nations and
countries from more
ruthless pirates and let's not forget
they gave the marines a massive fight in
the battle of marineford unfortunately
the fruit was stolen rather deviously by
blackbeard and we can only wonder how
he'll use his tremendous powers to
further his evil plan
one piece
it's time to unveil our top pick now and
the honor goes to
big mom's soul soul fruit which puts a
horrifying spin on the old halloween
tradition of trick or treat
the power of the soul-soul fruit makes
its use a manipulator of souls
as such big mom can extract the soul of
a person or a part of it and transfer it
into an inanimate object
bringing it to life that explains her
army of talking trees
flowers animals furnitures and cakes
they might look cute but like sugar's
toys
they're far from innocent beings the
soul extraction means the person who
parts with a portion of their soul loses
some part of their lifespan as well when
big moms being unreasonable
it might even come down to parting with
one's life the fruit also allows the
yonko to use portions of her soul to
create humanoid creatures called
incarnations that go about collecting
people's souls on her behalf however
there's a condition that must be
fulfilled for the soul souls fruit to
work which is that the target must be
afraid of the user given big mom's
insatiable hunger pangs and the
destruction she's capable of at times
this isn't a difficult ask at all
[Music]
and that's it the top 10 overpowered
devil fruit powers in one piece i hope
you enjoyed watching this video press
like if you did you can also subscribe
to my channel
vinnie tube for more anime and one piece
content the comment field is open to you
as well so don't hesitate to write in
and tell me about your favorite devil
fruit powers or anything else you'd like
to share i'll see you soon with a new
video
till then stay safe
you